um küsten du mich jetzt einfach so hat
es mal wieder geschafft ihr befindet
euch hier auf den beschichteten kanal in
youtube deutschland weltweit
wir reagieren heute gemeinsam zusammen
auf die neue hilfe folge hashtag köln
barros wer ist der größte babo der stadt
ich wohne in köln also das bin dann wohl
ich also ich denke eigentlich dass ich
der größte muffin ganz köln bin deswegen
ist eigentlich unnötig dass wir uns
dieses video anschauen aber wir gucken
erst mal worum es überhaupt geht paul 15
musste mit seiner mutter petra 38 in
eine andere stadt ziehen weil sie sich
von pauls vater getrennt hat der junge
nimmt ihr das richtig übel und gibt ihr
die alleinige schuld an der trennung
erschwerend hinzu kommt der umstand dass
petra ausgerechnet an pauls neuer schule
den posten als direktorin angenommen hat
frau sieht darin die perfekte
gelegenheit seiner mutter ziemlich übel
mitzuspielen auf diese weise will er sie
dazu bringen zu seinem vater zurück zu
kehren gleich mit seiner ersten aktion
bei der er auf dem schuldach einen
silvesterböller zündet erntet er bei
seinen mitschülern großen respekt
sondern dass nikolai lukas und anna sind
für alles zu begeistern was ich gegen
die schule richtet um die clique immer
stärker zu beeindrucken setzt paul bei
jeder neuen aktion noch einen drauf dh
der liebe paul der wahrscheinlich diese
person hier direkt in der ersten szene
ist nicht damit einverstanden dass sich
seine eltern getrennt haben und er wohnt
jetzt in köln und will direkt beweisen
dass er dort der größte babo ist hier
das geht nicht dass bin schon ich mache
hier nämlich auch ganz harte sachen
[Musik]
ja ich würde sagen wir fangen hier
einfach mal an und drücke auf play
hier läuft paul raus irgendwo aus seiner
schule wahrscheinlich erst jetzt auf dem
dach
erst mal ein paar push ups machen also
entzündet jetzt tatsächlich hier den
böller an auf dem schuldach dies hat
ganze hoch v
ich will das nicht anschauen
ich würde sagen bevor wir uns diesen
schwachsinn weiter anschauen gucken wir
uns erst mal kurz einige kommentare
unter dem video an heftiger motherfucker
das hat der pauli auch selbst schon
gesagt richtiger gangster mit sein
feuerwerk hh genau location von krasse
schule alles klar also anscheinend ist
diese location wo hier diese folge hilf
mir gedreht wurde
die gleiche location wurfkraft schule
gedreht wurde das ist auch so eine harte
serie auf rtl
wollt ihr dass ich da auch mal darauf
reagiere dann schreib mir gern mal eine
folge in die kommentare dieser moment
wenn du in köln wohnt und jetzt umziehen
willst ich glaube so wie es mir nach
dieser folge auch geben wetten luca
reagiert darauf kann sein ich will
hühnchen mit reis schöne grüße gehen
raus und pascal an der stelle köln
bambus könnte auch ein klarname von
fordert schweizern sein
wenn ich da rein monat monat ab
zu bekommen wir schmeißen ich meine ps4
aus dem fenster hat also wir sehen schon
mit welchen leuten wir es hier zu tun
haben allerdings würde ich sagen wir
schauen uns mal weiter die folge an
alles gar nicht immer wieder kurz doch
jetzt haben die auch noch köln babos
shirts an was ist er mit euch das sind
wahrscheinlich die freunde von dem gerät
also doch ein zünden
das ist ja fremdschämen tour feiern
wollen hey was faul das ist dann
wahrscheinlich die mutter petra die
jetzt der rektorin ist dann hast du ja
er hat einen knall hat der feuerwerk
dabei wir müssen auch so eine klasse
aktion starten nicht dass es uns ja
eigene clique eröffnet mensch das wäre
der weltuntergang pratersch einfach
keinen gedanken
das ist meine sorge sein ich habe das
schon plan
der anführer der kölner bar boss hat
gesprochen da ich hier auf die chance
wie so ungezogen ich bin ja auch ne kopf
oder du gehst jetzt auf der stelle in
der unterricht zurück und da kommt
nichts ist der neuntgrößte zum film ja
das bin doch ich nach der aktion
lasst mich in ruhe damit jeder auch
dieser schöne weiß dass ich begrüße aber
auf dieser schule mehr als das sein
das ist weiter da und ein kalter auf
jeden fall bringen das wird sofort
eingestellt
ihr habt noch recht alle gehöriges rat
an eurem packwagen aber keine option
es ist falsch wir machen das trotzdem
und jetzt kommen wir die mutter ihr
wieder an
das sind doch nicht der ehren von den
leuten in der redaktion da ich dachte
die wollen das ist irgendwie vernünftig
machen sena wenn die mutter da jetzt
dann erstmal den typen den sohn da
irgendwie vom dach runter holt und dann
war in armenien box wenn er jetzt an der
neuen schule ist es ist ganz wichtig
dass er dazugehört
deswegen ist die clique für ihn gold
werden jetzt muss ich natürlich mit den
minions um die ecke das ist mehr als
peinlich ja du bist auch mehr als
peinlich habt ihr nicht burg heute abend
einfach mal was zu machen was bewegt ist
dann hingehalten unsere kappe mit
japanischer
die kläger ihr seid auch recht komplett
am arsch wasser ist einfach eine richtig
geile aktion
dk
was
ok also er hat jetzt den schlüssel von
seiner markt gesorgt
und jeder kriegt der trägen die sonne
sonnenbaden geschnallt jetzt
jetzt brechen die schule ein
du siehst aus wie
vollidiot einfach dann auch noch sondern
möchte gern mit will musik jetzt hier
was das lehrerzimmer
hallo
ich habe auch immer eine tastatur ohne
bildschirm darum stehen hält er fest
dass der rhythmus für die reisen sind ja
einfach das sind alles packen
ohne bildschirm bei der tastatur als
wenn die lehrer da im lehrerzimmer sonst
hätte rumliegen haben mit den lösungen
für die klausuren und hey was packt ev
jetzt bin ich gespannt
pd
der geist ihr seid
das so amann
kamera läuft haben alles sah leute ihr
seht ihr mal was ein richtiger kölner
bar gemacht
mal schauen was er da hin sprüht
wahrscheinlich pathos
oh mein gott das der peinlichste
den ich je gesehen habe muss jetzt so
sehen zu sichern von direktorin ist ja
normal dass die arbeiten haben karten
kostet nichts besseres zu
also ich finds echt wahnsinnig krass
diesmal ist es nicht so dass man
irgendwie eine person hat die voller
matsch oder so sondern vier personen die
komplett am arsch sind als ich meine der
und die die sagen bisher irgendwie
nichts hast du das was mit dem zu machen
und stunden dieses mädel ist eigentlich
mit diesem anderen kölner labor zusammen
aber jetzt macht die sich an den rand
der welt größere babo ist hat der
einbruch nummer darüber gestartet haben
ich finde man band nicht mehr ja wenn
meine mutter das nie im beruf findet ja
keine ahnung was dabei ist diese 15
jährige anna eigentlich komplett
wahnsinnig diese erst mit diesem anderen
typ mit diesem nicolai oder wie der
heißt zusammen und jetzt müsst ihr den
einfach und küsten du mich jetzt einfach
sowas kusel okay der paule tipps zu
hause dass ich natürlich dass eine cap
auf ihr siegertänzchen nahmen gleich
ankommen
du hast du das immer mal das kann ich ja
ganz genau sagen
dieses armband habe ich in meinem zimmer
in der schule gefunden
paul
bis 10
gerade am arsch du kannst ja mal schön
gedanken machen wie du die schneiderei
da wieder weg machen willst dann ist für
dich das wochenende mit seinem vater
gestorben
das was man mal ganz kurz sagen muss die
mutter ist die einzige in dieser folge
die vernünftig schauspielern kann dies
ja an jeder hilfe reaktion von mir sage
es geht überhaupt nicht gegen die leute
wirklich die die schauspieler sind oder
so dahinter das heißt wenn ich mich
jetzt über die mutter lustig machte war
oder über den paul nicolai anna pascal
keine ahnung wen dann geht es nie gegen
die leute sondern nur gegen die
gespielte rolle also ich möchte
überhaupt niemanden beleidigen ich finde
es ehrlich gesagt sogar sehr unterhalts
haben diese serie hommel mal die anderen
zusammen rüstungs treffen muss man mit
reden ja okay jetzt kommt es wohl zu
einem letzten treffen der köln barbie
die berechnet wieder in die schule ein
da waren wir dann hier und was soll da
schon ja gut dass die toilette
geschissen
ich
also die wollten gerade in die schule
einbrechen jetzt kommt dieser
hausmeister hier an und fragt was die da
machen oder sagt der pauli gut
juli geschlossen das ist es eine
spontane richtig gute reaktion gewesen
nicht auf die toilette sondern grün köln
porz auf den boden der sporthalle der
paul macht einfach weiter
der hausarrest kann ich eh nicht mehr
kriegen die alle springer die wird schon
sehen zu wem einem anhalten wird wenn es
darauf ankommt
[Musik]
es war ja was jetzt die strafe das mit
dem wochenende mit papa ich will einfach
nur weiter schauen
an dieser stelle würde ich meine
reaktion auf die folge köln bus von
hilft mir jetzt allerdings auch beenden
meine damen und herren wenn ich meine
reaktion gefallen hat das gerne wahr
einen like das schreibt mir gerne unter
die kommentare ob ich mal auf krass
schule reagieren soll
das ist so eine andere serie auf rtl 2
lich sehen letzter zeit viele kommentare
unter videos von mir von wegen haye
reagiert wieder auf hilfen mir blabla
ich möchte nur einmal pro woche auf so
eine serie reagieren
ich möchte jetzt keine action kanal
werden der jeden tag irgendwie auf hilfe
reagiert und blabla das finde ich ein
bisschen eintönig und da würde ich mich
auch nicht gut bei führen ich möchte
auch weiter einen typischen anderen turm
content bringen sag ich mal also adtv
reaktionen auf irgendwelche rtl2 serien
oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung
kommen bei mir immer einmal pro woche am
wochenende heim und übrigens falls ihr
euch fragt was das hier für einen
sticker who die am ersten zwölfter kommt
dieser rudi hier den shop also
tatsächlich in einer woche anschaut da
gern mal vorbei und jetzt kommt das aus
rom
[Musik]